comment ça va ça
on sort du respect bonsoir tous les
trois au gaz qu'est ce que vous
ressentez à l'idée de montrer s'il m'a
hyper enthousiaste très sexy mais on a
hâte d'en découdre de le montrer en fait
de voir
montrer le travail tout ça toute la
populace joey vous devez être cher vous
devez être fier c'est de l'eau non il
n'y a pas un potentiel gueule mais
presque
non pour moi pour ça mais non je suis
super faire mes choix je suis personne
du film film et argent
super faire toute moralité mcad
le monopole c'est grâce à eux c'était
quoi le défi principal pour vous deux
pas de les respecter à l'idée paraît
qu'ils soient contents du truc voilà et
puis de le rendre hommage je crois parce
qu'ils nous ont bercés nous ont fait
rêver nous ont fait vibrer raison et
c'est la musique d'aujourd'hui encore et
celles qui ont ouvert les portes et ça
nous fait plaisir de les représenter ce
soir et d'être là joué par exo il a il a
capté quoi tout il a su faire ressortir
quoi de vous en sortir
oui là puissent comprendre quoi de nous
quoi de votre personnalité
mais je pense que
non c'est surtout c'est surtout c'est
pas que le personnage c'est l'époque
tous que ça transpire en fait je pense
que les deux ont réussi à envoyer ça
quand vous parlez pas mais comment vous
avez appris à bouger comme ça
deux ans de travail comme travail
l'acharnement de sueur de sang de
douleur de tout ce que tu veux et voilà
le travail de travail ou de travailler
les gens qui nous entoure est au top
nitish le coach incroyable à la voile à
tout pour gwladys thierno karim commères
tous ces gens là qui nous ont mis tant
est qu'ils nous ont vraiment accompagner
tous les os des retours tous ceux qui
sont avec nous dans le coup dans le
possible la voilà vous savez tout ce
qu'ils ont fait partie de l'aventuré
fait jouer vous qu'être comédien et
comédien voit un conflit ans mais
maintenant vous pensez quoi de ces deux
là ils vont aller loin ah je pense
qu'ils sont super généreux parce que
tous prévoient comme je le disais sur le
film et il en est
ils ont été tous les rendez vous
à autant de retentir la tique sur le
côté performances athlétiques
ce décret bon challenger challenge est
assis là je pense que voilà mon avis on
chan dans une continuité on n'y est pas
prête de s'arrêter